[Music]
good morning Millennials good morning
Millennials I'm afraid to look over at
the stream because I'm wearing a chunky
sweater a lot Jackson busy Vegas season
one Vanderpump rules and I'm just like
nervous what it's doing to my physique
so I'm about to look over do you see
what it looks like I don't see yet I'm
curious what I look like because my
track record this week has been awful
Alex said I thought we're winners have
looked around this even though the
pilgrim shirt yesterday looked better
than I thought his head sitting here
looking at the stream I look fine I just
look like a people UMP of Cole I look a
little mannish but it's just a regular
Tuesday for your girl grunge I look like
a lump of coal what an have you been
naughty or 9 24 hours since I last sat
here you yeah no you more you Oh God
okay no I wasn't busy actually was very
busy what did he do did I create a
content with TPG I was on the pointes
guy's podcast called talking points
which you know I'm obsessed with him and
I just like praised everything he does
but that name is genius for sure because
they're talking about points and here
are some talking points at that point
it's available in the App Store if you
want any highlights lowlights TLDR um I
actually listen to it I know I've never
listened to an episode of the toast in
my life I've never listened to any
podcast I've been on I just like hate
the sound of my own voice but this
podcast we kept it really tight it was
30 minutes we were just like laughing so
much she's so funny I don't even
remember we just talked about like
travel pet peeves LaGuardia Delta things
like that by the way my life has been
changed ever since I learned that it's
poor adequate to put your seat back on a
plane well I was talking about that with
him as well so you know how I sleep on
the tray table and like if I'm asleep on
the tray table and someone puts their
seat snap you're not there's a chance
that there's a neck snapping so while I
was on the plane this weekend I was
sleeping on the table but not well
every time the person went to push their
chair back I push I good I held firm and
they couldn't get back no I just assumed
it was broken
well TBG said it's not proper airline
etiquette we were also talking about
like aggressive recline I was like
there's a way to recline if you're going
to like lovely like you're on a beach in
San Tropez like I know but those people
who keep like jamming it back like I
could go Mel it's like you tuned in one
sail Subban what if you have a drink on
the table no it's didn't break her
computer - yes my iPad was like under
the table top and it's Lynn and the
kings and so I also while I was air
applied for a credit card I got
the rose gold emic I applied yesterday
as we did yeah because the plea knee
vibes I just appreciate and it's over
tomorrow like you can't get the credit
card in pink after tomorrow so I just
like obviously I did it at the very last
minute I just wanted a pink credit card
and it's oh four times points on dining
which is like all I spend my money on
and dining and it's toasty as hell and
that's why if you go to Point sky.com
slash toast you can get yours one more
day only one night I really made it to
the last minute on that one I know we've
been talking about it ever since he was
here we're like we're gonna get it but
then what happened was I was out with
friends last week and someone else was
talking about I was like those are my
talking points oh my god how do they
step on your talking toes so then I was
like wow like if it's if it's just like
that one that's how I learned nothing
that the Chase Sapphire well I was
talking about you on the podcast I'm
like my sister Jackie accidentally got
the Chase Sapphire Preferred and he
works very closely with Chase and I'm
like I just think you should talk to
them because the wording is very
confusing you would assume that the
Chase Sapphire Preferred is preferred
over the reserve and he said you know
that's actually an excellent point he
never thought of it that way and he's
gonna talk to them about it Wow thank
you and acting change also the swipe on
the car doesn't work maybe they can make
that a little stronger and for next time
well it's not supposed to swipe it's a
chip that's why no but like it used to
work this wipe but now it doesn't so now
I have to hold two cards Swiper no
swiping
I know and it's not swiping that's for
damn sure that's for damn sure
oh also yesterday we told you guys that
I wouldn't be here tomorrow but I didn't
realize the genius businesswoman that I
am I always try but my flights so I can
make the toast too
so I head to Columbus at 2 o'clock and I
can certainly make the choice as long as
I'm out of here by like 11:30 people say
you got to leave for the airport extra
early because did you the government
shutdown yes so I was in bed the other
day when I found out the government was
shut down and apparently it's been shut
down for quite some time and that was a
real moment for me to like get my head
out of my ass cuz I think I actively
like a couple maybe like a year ago
decided it's like no longer be invested
in what's going on in the world because
it's too upsetting and it really it's
taken a lot off my mind but then I
realize I'm like the government has been
shut down for a month
and I didn't know about it like that's
bad and that's like really like I don't
want to be that you know airhead ish
right
how do I'm gonna make a little bit more
of an investment in learning what's
going on in the world but I just they
say you got to get to the airport early
because TSA people are calling and say
because they're not getting paid yes so
I was actually at a story
they're calling in sick but they are
still working technically and I did
travel this weekend and I've never
experienced shorter lines ever what also
like then the government shutdown I
thought it might affect the post office
but it doesn't a lot of the things that
like are that you would rely on the
transit um public transit I think that's
like but that's not the state okay and
then also what's gonna be crazy it's tax
season it's coming up oh and why IRS
workers like our government employees
imaginary all the taxes of the year
we're just like foregone because of the
government shutdown or our wait I have a
question if the government's not working
a few days out of the year shouldn't our
taxes be less because they're not
working out a hundred percent how many
days has it been shut down
I think it's been two or three weeks
shook yeah it's like filibuster season
or not filibuster season no I'm gonna
actually pull up a story about the TSA
um just to help you okay in your travels
okay because with the government
shutdown threatening paychecks more TSA
agents are calling sick out-of-work
quote if you don't have a check to pay
your bills what are you going to do
honestly I feel that it's not unusual
for airport security agents tasked with
screening passengers to call out sick
and noticeable numbers after the
holidays but with a partial government
shutdown entering its third week and
threatening to deny the nation's 51,000
Transport Security Administration
employees involved in the screening
process a pay check on Friday the idea
that more and more agents might be
no-shows at checkpoints could have a
cascading effect through airports and
lead to longer lines makes sense but you
have pre-check and clear so you're in
the clear yeah and I spoke about that a
lot with TPG as well you know was only
thirty minutes but it really felt like a
lifetime I went to his office to it's
all like designed like an airport so the
elevators are like economy in
first-class and the snacks in the in
like the reception area like are in bins
that like they pass out on the planes
very cute very cute also I flew American
this weekend and it was really I have an
opening experience I think American is
like one of the most overrated airlines
like it's it's spirit level it depends
where did you go and come from Dallas to
LaGuardia I mean so when you're flying
out of LaGuardia you like automatically
get the worst flights but if you fly
American out of JFK to my
I mean you can get a life flatbed and
it's like the best like just an economy
I mean like like Zach was sitting in his
chair with the person in front of him
back and like it was literally so small
he made and I'm a small person and like
it was like it was I don't I can't
imagine it possibly being any smaller
I don't fly American but people act like
oh it's like American Delta no no Delta
American spirit
JetBlue JetBlue yeah tbg says JetBlue
the greatest commercial airline in the
u.s. the greatest commercial airline
since song o total you keep asking the
back song you know I didn't I guess I'll
have to go back for a follow-up episode
oh I know how you'll hate that I know I
just have to go back to his office and
eating all the snacks again to
dog-friendly office CHEO supposed to
bring thea but I [ __ ] up yeah for
those of you don't know um this weekend
it's a big day it's a big weekend it's
actually it's a long weekend holiday
weekend of nephew's weekend out I will
be taking care of Theo from Wednesday
Wednesday Sunday and I'm so excited and
it's really I just I think about it and
talk about it all the time and it's like
Zach's going on he's talking about achoo
though that's the thing right it's a
mutual excitement actually on his
bachelor party this weekend and it's
like ordinarily I'd be sad FOMO like
miss you bye but it's like I'm so
excited about Theo I'm not gonna notice
no he's like was up all night being like
that's what he said it was really sweet
oh my god maybe he'll make me some of
his borscht if it gets cold but did you
get a second pair of em Jimmy shoes I
saw that you did I was trying to yeah
what kind gonna get well because the
ones that I got for the sneakers the
first round that we got the same ones
which is hilarious um I wear them all
the time for so I wear them on the show
all the time I wear them every single
time I go to the airport because they're
easy to slip on and off and out there
and I'm Elysia so I just want another I
just want um nice white sneakers that I
could like wear with a dress like a
summer dress that don't have the black
panel over them right well Jackie and
I've been talking about em Jimmy like
for a month now they're the greatest
Italian luxury shoes not at the same
prices you can think of like Gucci but
they're made really in the same way so
you can go see for yourself how amazing
these shoes are at MGM e.com slash toast
and make sure you shop their biggest
sale of the year where you can get up to
$200 off styles you need to hurry now
the sale ends January 14th
that's letters mg
mi dot-com / toast I'm Jimmy calm /
toast Italian luxury mid the old way
sold in a way I love a catchy
catchphrase you know no totally that's
that one sticks with you yeah no way
sold the new way M Jimmy precious and
Jimmy of a man oh my gosh so bed is
working on like a campaign and I was
like last night at dinner like trying to
come up with really good ideas and I
think I came up with literally the
greatest idea but I don't know if I
could say it you know I feel like
they're gonna use it how about you -
like don't tell us the brand or the idea
but just us okay
so it's a brand and the brand's
competitor they're really worried about
the competitor and Ben's like I don't
even know why like I haven't seen him
seen their commercials I'm like I have
they have this huge celebrity so I said
that Ben should do an just as big of a
TV campaign with that celebrity's wife
and I'll explain afterwards wide spirit
and if they ever do it I'm gonna take
credit for it it's such a good idea that
it's a great brand that's a great idea
and it's like she came then they should
do like his ex-girlfriend or something
no no it only works for the wife when
you know who these people are okay now
I'm thinking yeah no you won't guess but
I'll tell you afterwards
now I'm thinking yo wheels of I just I
don't know like you know I can't say I
can't like speak on like some
confidential information that definitely
that by the way sounds completely
confidential except for and so ideas
aren't confidential but like you know if
it's sold through would be confidence
right no I just like I want to say it
now so like if that ever comes to
fruition we could prove back to this
episode because I know Ben's I think
this is no one else has done that and
you know if other people are watching a
lot of people a lot of toasters work in
the marketing advertising industry so
that idea might be stolen as well but
good for you if they're too slow on it
it should someone should are you ready
what else did I do yes ray I think I'm
ready I did all wedding stuff yesterday
and I did actually nothing oh my god I
started surviving our Kelly oh I know oh
my god I know I'm gonna start it and
it's it's the Oh watch with you know it
was too scary for him okay so I kept
notes in and I just have to say like I
think our Kelly was very much before our
time like and and the whole Aaliyah
thing I didn't know anything about but
what's so shocking about the whole thing
it's like yes he's this enormous monster
but the people are like how many however
many people knew about what was going on
and like even the public knew because
there were tapes really seni got to go
to court like now even as someone who's
like a well learning adult I knew who
our Kelly was I didn't know any of this
like it's it's amazing how many people
knew and how nobody talked about it and
all people talked about was that he peed
on someone no it's so terrible in the
video that like with the peeing he's
having sex with a 14 year old girl and
he pees in her mouth yeah it's very
graphic light time hear that like they
joke that are Kelly peed on someone like
starts from that video that everyone saw
but it's like that's what we it's child
porn takeaway well right and that's what
people in the thing are saying they're
like it was ripped off bootleg like
being sold in flea markets like when VHS
is were thing and like you buy a VHS on
the street like it was there like in
Queens like this guy who was her
basketball coach he was I got hurt a
flea market and saw it oh yeah I'm gonna
watch it so that you can talk about it
and the weirdest part about all of this
which you and I wouldn't once you watch
it I want to discuss but and I hate to
bring it up but it's the lady Gaga bat
all what do you mean
so are Kelly has pretty much been banned
from the music industry for a while but
homegirl made a song with him five years
ago do what you want what you want with
my body and that's what they were saying
about him there's an episode episode
called hidden in plain sight like he
literally used to write songs that cut
ages just a number
like literally saying what he did and
nobody even realized so do what you want
what you want with me
you know what time that people didn't
realize because it seems like everybody
realized that like no one that cared
character or wanted to do anything about
it
no and so like I'm not I'm not I'm not
sure where I where I fall and I need to
do some research okay because when they
were working together like she did say
something like you know we connect
because we've both been accused of
things we didn't do that's what I read
somewhere and I'm not sure if top 200
untrue and just as she's someone who's
rarely outspoken and was a victim of
sexual assault I just find it weird okay
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna watch it it's
Pittsville that a lot like are Kelly is
a monster and like you know how that you
read things on NT and you're like no
one's that disgusting or that crazy or
that protected yes they are
and do they have it all comes back they
have is what that is they have a second
wife in there what do you mean she's a
part of the documentary like she's
testimony
yeah she's so brave he locked her up he
used to lock up people okay I also do
want to like experience myself it's
[ __ ] shook I'm that's terrible
also speaking of TV we will be recapping
the bachelor and Vanderpump girls
because we did not stop working last
night for hours of content only one and
when I thought Vanderpump pearls was two
hours because it was mother I couldn't
live a bachelor was three hours the
nerve oh my god what's so crazy is I got
home late I got home at like 8:30 saying
I turned on my TV I realized I didn't
have it recorded so I started recording
from like 836 or whatever and then when
I sat down later to watch 836 was right
when the show actually started by the
girls finger that [ __ ] in the beginning
thank God so stupid and like it's like
they have created through their show
like so many like really top to your
influencers and I think they never knew
how to work with them and like bring it
back to the show
and so now it's like now 10 years later
they have Jojo and Ashley and Kaitlyn
and it's a good idea but like too little
too late no and it's like too much too
soon like yes one of those I mean I
can't with their their watch party so
stupid nobody has a watch party unless
they know that ABC's coming to film it
right and it's just like makes me sad I
like even I guess what Joe Joe and
Kaylin didn't Dallas at a bar is is
cooler but like there's so many better
week better things to do think it was
like so stupid the proposal oh my god I
was dying of shame same okay without
further ado here are the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast already just gonna preface
some of these stories are you know
today's news some of them came out
either over the weekend or late last
week and today was a slow day and
they're worth discussing okay okay
there's like two stories like thank you
for the preface right because I don't
want you guys to think that like we're
lacking words like this is stale toaster
you're watching an old episode right if
you've read II read this story which you
probably haven't it wasn't talked about
it the first story is fresh off the
presses Margot Robbie is set to star as
Mattel's live-action Barbie oh my god we
win Marie when did we report Amy Schumer
supposed to stars Barbie but scheduling
conflicts and the premise of the movie
is like it's sort of like else it's like
she gets kicked out of Barbie land for
not being perfect and then she's in the
real world like as a doll we that's
really annoying that Amy Schumer isn't
gonna do it because you'd be perfect not
only she'd be perfect that seems like
something you rearrange your schedule
for right so she I pray that
well this has been going on for so long
now whereas schedule should be free we
were casting Reese Witherspoon remember
like yes like a year ago oh we need to
go look at all this will but I really
said Margot Robbie yeah because it had
to be someone because it's someone like
in their 30s I believe so Amy Schumer
and Anne Hathaway who was also supposed
to do it are out and Margot Robbie is in
as Barbie okay and that I being out is
just like the best oh thank you know
she's gonna be incredible except she is
Barbie like this is supposed to be like
a Barbie misfit right so like it made
sense if Amy Schumer who was like a
loudmouth like that would would have
made a little bit more sense of like
perfect everything Margaret
don't get me wrong and now I'm really
excited see Margot Robbie as Barbie but
like really I feel as if it was a missed
opportunity for so many reasons with Amy
Schumer and I'm a little upset first
sure but I'm I'm trusting Marc Robbie
Mattel Warner Brothers have announce
that the I Tanja Oscar nominee is set to
fill the role once announced for both
actresses at the 2017 cinema cinema
society and Svedka party for her film
and fun mom dinner director Alethea
Jones seemed to confirm rumors that Anne
Hathway would starring her live-action
Barbie flick at the Times Jones was
overheard talking about casting Hathaway
in the Sony movie after Amy Schumer
dropped out due to scheduling conflicts
very sad
oh also she's pregnant Amy Schumer well
now what so maybe she knew she was gonna
be very no like she probably when barbie
was supposed to film she was probably
filming I feel pretty which by the way
is an important move and then this has
been a like on the back burner for so
long and ash and like so maybe they
would have gotten her again but she's
pregnant
right right right so it didn't seem like
that Mattel really made this a priority
no but they show because the premise is
just so good and also I even though
Margot Robbie is aesthetically perfect
you know one nobody's perfect
but she's really really close and two
she did transform for I Tania into this
the bull Vaughn of the century she's a
very good transformative physical
actress right so like it doesn't make
sense she is Barbie but maybe like on
the inside that her personality it's too
big or something for a Barbie land it's
just like only margot robbie could play
Mary Queen of Scots and Barbie right and
Tonya Harding and Tonya Harding and just
like everything else and just I love her
and I'll oppose she like has like a nice
quiet marriage you know what I mean
because like her sexuality or like her
dating to like rise her star because she
doesn't have to right she's you talented
and now I'm just so excited for this
movie they say there's no way it's gonna
be bad
no we go you have a plus star and just
an a-plus story and I know but I hope
they really do an a-plus soundtrack by
the way it's life-size who do we need
like redoing I'm a Barbie girl
we need like Ke$ha no we don't need okay
we do a lipeh yeah or bebe Rexha bebe
Rexha yeah actually I love doing lip I
love them both ya know they're both
really good but like do Libous on a song
with Andreea Bocelli and every time I
favorite she's so good like she really
rises to the challenge but still sounds
like a pop star but what holds her own
but holds her own good for her you guys
should listen to it anyway it's just
just some exciting news to kick off the
morning and this is now our second story
is the story that I chose for you okay
law and order correct creator Dick Wolf
is splitting from his third wife I heard
after nearly 12 years of marriage law
and order creator Dick Wolf is
reportedly splitting from his third wife
Noel Lippmann wolf 72 filed court
documents asking her a legal separation
from the almost blue actress on December
3rd according to documents obtained by
TMZ wolf rep by LA lawyers jokey Bray
and Jacqueline me show that's when me
show problems allegedly claims in the
filing that there's a prenuptial
agreement according to the website in
the response to Wolf's request for
separation his wife filed her own
documents asking for a legal separation
Friday Lippmann is asking for spousal
support according to the documents
how much does Dick Wolf worth right
that's the big question here because
like he is someone who was just quietly
modeling yeah I read I was following the
story on John Joe and they said he's
making like 20 million a month or
something what yeah can you look up his
net worth okay
he's like I feel like one of the richest
men in Hollywood I mean is it a show
with 17 seasons 20 on NBC like a huge
cable network and it has um like they
are spin-offs no spin-offs and what's
the word what friends has
lt's syndication syndication it plays on
USA he is worth 350 million dollars
according to submarine net worth calm
okay celebritynetworth.com also said my
net worth is 250 thousand which is just
completely untrue I wish so I don't
let's just take that with a small grain
of salt right but I feel like they have
a better job analyzing Dick Wolf
they have a better job analyzing people
with actual money right it's easier to
see yeah so this is like sad but I bet
he'll like you know get married again oh
my god Richmond always hit Mary like
seven seventy two year olds that's wild
what does she look like me she's an
actress I'm always shocked when rich
older men date someone who's like above
the age of 40 yeah nobody 35 it's
shocking
truly they have two kids together who
are eight and 11 so all I'm hearing is
that Dick Wolf is looking for a new wife
who's also an actress and I just have to
say I'll take it even though you're not
age-appropriate technically no but I'm
an old soul I've been told that many a
times you are I have a soul about of a
71 year old so we're all set
perfect but and I would wake up every
morning and I just roll over to dick and
they'd be like dick in the criminal
justice system sexually-based offenses
are considered especially heinous
and in New York City right here the tip
of the kid detectives who investigate
these vicious felonies yeah they're
members of an elite squad known as the
Special Victims Unit
ever heard of it look it up sweetie
these are their [ __ ] stories
[ __ ] done done what do you have a
breakfast I'm gonna launch I'm gonna use
that as a launching pad into our next
story because this is ways someone also
just said not only does he have dick the
lon honor he also does all those Chicago
shows okay to see him he does Chicago PD
Chicago med Chicago Fire oh my god he's
rich okay you watched any of those shows
no but their commercials are so
inspiring because essentially they're
all they're three separate shows about
like Chicago departments departments and
they weave into each other two
crossovers that is so smart
Sophia Bush was on it like she was in an
episode also once with Marcia Carter
today like they needed this of Chicago
reinforcements jurisdiction you know
they're really smart like that yeah
that's like when Disney did this be like
of Hannah Montana in the house exactly
anyways
will you do the law and order intro
again because it'll really cue us into
our next story which is made for law and
order
okay Lord
I can't say it even while I was reading
this story like if I say just without
thinking law and order that's not so
it's like uber it's law and order it's
hard only true connoisseurs can say law
and honor
it's kind of like the reader in the
criminal justice system sexually-based
offenses are considered especially nice
to New York City the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies but in unit these are the
stories sent on woman in vegetative
state for 10 years I'm gonna start again
woman in vegetative state for 10 years
gives birth to a baby sparking
investigation
this ain't me the thing is it's like I
only read headlines and this is like the
only story that you really only need to
read that no and there's so much to
unpack know there in this headline there
is like so much not like it's like that
there's that old I don't know I learned
it in the lived literature class it's
like just one sentence and it's baby
shoes for sale never worn what does it
mean very sad
wait why did you just say that that's
like a the most depressing thing that's
like an example of it just in that one
sentence there's so much who the [ __ ]
was teacher Hitler like I've never heard
about that so I was like maybe the baby
was born with a bigger foot expected no
that's so sad
Oh Jaggi maybe it was a boy and they
were expecting a girl in there freely
okay okay I like right so that like I
turned it on her head
don't worry you showed that teacher you
sure showed Hitler its Ernest Hemingway
of course but anyways so it's just one
of those things yeah you know like like
I said that the title is all you need
right and it's like I'm an expert in
this story because I read the headline a
title says a thousand words
an Arizona healthcare facility is
investigating what it calls quote deeply
disturbing incident that deeply deeply
that a local television television
station has said involved the alleged
sexual assault of a patient in the
vegetative state
resulting in the birth of a baby I'm
gonna use real laughter no I don't want
to laugh like it's a mystery
realize that I tried to pretend I was a
patient at Hacienda health care
long-term facility for the
developmentally disabled gave birth to a
baby boy on December 29th
according to phoenix-based news outlet
que pho TV which also reported that the
patient has been a vegetative state for
at least a decade after nearly drowning
the outlet attributed its report to a
single unnamed source who had reportedly
been told about the incident a patient
is considered in a vegetative state when
he or she is a week but not showing
signs of awareness according to the Mayo
Clinic in a statement two people on
Friday Hacienda Healthcare spokesman
David Lebovitz
said the organization which runs the
facility was cooperating with law
enforcement but declined to divulge the
exact nature of the underlying incident
I thought I like calling someone like a
vegetable or like that sheet it was like
not a thing you could do I think calling
them a vegetable is what's offensive
because it's derivative of vegetative
which is the medical term oh it is yes
okay okay I just thought it like wasn't
cool and I was just like she's on life
support you know yeah she's in a
vegetative state and then right
this story is a Pitts Hill USA but you
know that we'd like to turn things into
hallmark movies I have come up with an
alternate reason why this happened
because everything happens for a reason
and and here it is it's expensive to
keep someone like on constant oxygen
whatever when your invention saying you
need to be on like a full medical and
you need to be taken care of like that's
expensive and these her family's been
paying for it for 10 years it's obvious
that like they won't they can't let go
like a lot of people would just like
pull the plug and and and let the person
die peacefully but this family honestly
can't let go so I think in some weird
way because no matter what happens this
guy's going to jail so they're getting a
child maybe like people who really
needed it I don't know I'm trying think
of like a Hallmark anything for it you
know perhaps this is such a [ __ ]
terrible thing but it's like you look at
that child and all you think is it's
like the treachery and necrophilia
behind me so who do we think it was like
a nurse well so then there's a follow up
story that the facility where a woman in
vegetative state gave birth was sighted
after a staff walked in on nude patients
oh this oh this place going out of
business
oh I mean of course but they have prior
citations and yeah who do you think it
is someone who works there obviously
right like janitor nurse doctor
disgust like maybe like someone else's
visitor oh yeah you know I just think
there's no greater injustice than like
when things like this happen in a
medical facility because you're really
supposed to think like people pay a lot
of money and like put a lot of their
trust into like nursing homes or rehab
facilities so when when these kinds of
terrible things happen at a place like
that it makes it so much worse like she
was supposed to be safe for sure but
like that's where these horrible things
happens because like really no one's
paying attention totally there's just so
many people who need help it's really
sad it's so terrible anyways this story
is like wild if you didn't know it now
you know and we will continue to update
you the CEO of the center resigned today
good good but we'll continue to update
you as we get more information because
but so what now also here's a question
she gave birth so they've known for a
while she was pregnant no they found out
she was pregnant cuz she was like
moaning and labor but she didn't have a
belly like I mean that's should then
that's negligence yes not knowing
someone's pregnant is yes also
negligence and this is a weird question
but if you're in a vegetative state
would you be getting your period every
month I don't know any question yet and
if you're in a vegetative state you
can't push what they do a c-section no
but like if the babies come like the
baby's coming so you have to push it out
though it doesn't come on its own for
sure but they definitely did a c-section
maybe there's more actually they barely
giving us any information I doubt they
gave us that level but yeah I don't know
and it's just so many like so many
things are Sippy about this I smell a
cover-up and it smells like a big fart
okay speaking of people who didn't know
that they were pregnant a woman gives
birth in the backseat of a New York City
Taxi great I'm sure I literally took it
this morning an expectant mom oh it was
one of the big ones today my god no but
thank God it was a tit not oh there was
another face you know because they have
these new ones that look like a
spaceship so it's actually it's
handi-capable and pregnant king there's
a ton of legroom on the floor that you
could have lied down for sure labor
capable to labor booked expectant mom
got it
of TLC Tuesday morning I think they mean
like the network when her baby was born
in the back of the yellow cab on the
Upper East Side fencing police got a
call for a woman in labor in a yellow
cab at 7:55 a.m. at the intersection of
70th Street and 2nd Avenue cop said the
baby was born without a hitch and
transported along with mom to New York
Presbyterian Weill Cornell Medical
Center on East 68th Street cop said both
mom and baby are doing fine great this
is so weird like it's like that episode
of Desperate Housewives when Lynette
they find out that the Scavo is the
twins friend is like the murderer who do
you murder Eddie he wasn't the one like
he he did hit Julie oh and because he
came from a bad home right there that
episode was so sad and Lynette really
saw the good in him and she gave birth
on his [ __ ] couch
it's a crazy look you think if you give
birth anywhere but a hospital like
you're both dead but it's really fine
like people I've been giving birth in
caves like for years well it could go
either way but it's like even if you
give birth in a hospital there could
still be complications or you could
break a cord around the neck which is
what happened to Lynette right or you
could give birth in the taxi cab and
smooth sailing but say you give birth
like I didn't know I was pregnant style
like what do you do to the umbilical
cord I mean I've seen you just someone
giving birth in that and then on that
show in the toilet at prom yeah but then
do you just get a scissor or do you like
I don't know because you're still
connected to the baby that's the thing
I'm here to say the umbilical cord thing
is weird also that little crusty thing
on a baby's belly is a car gross the
belly button and people like save it am
I gonna get into earrings would you eat
your placenta no I might why well it's
so good for you too helps with
postpartum depression I feel like I'm
definitely like a child but made for
that and maybe but how else is it good
for you other than just like it's just
so many nutrients like and I wouldn't
like eat it like with a fork and a knife
Kim Zolciak I think it was how to manage
it like a little pill capsule pills I
think about it you know I look at first
when I heard it I'm like that's weird in
Primal but in the more I think about it
it's like not that weird I would need to
see the list of I would need to
investigate I would do it um just for
the postpartum reason alone I feel like
that's my worst fear yes so if I can do
something to help I think I'll do it I
agree with you on that member in Tom
Scavo said he had postpartum like Tom
Scavo I
can't stress enough was the worst human
character husband and father like
Lynette is like ten months notice her
she's like a two month old baby six kids
working a job making the house run and
he comes home all sick and she's like
what's wrong go to the doctor he comes
right to the doctor and he's like I have
postpartum he's the worst
yeah but yes some men can have
postpartum I know someone's gonna be
[ __ ] for that for sure but it's it's a
woman's disease okay they want and they
want to take everything from us
Oh Matt had a major faux pas in the TPG
podcast because he was saying after me
he's in interviewing the CEO of clear
because we were talking about clear so
Mike I have a message for the CEO tell
him whatever and he's like it's actually
her I said the patriarchy has trade we
believe that a CEO is a man it's not my
fault
Wow I know it was really bad and then I
said it again Oh what if I knew it was a
woman I might tell him Wow I made two
major footballs and then you and then
you said it again on the show on the
show but it's good it's better than
someone else calling you out no yeah and
I'm aware of my own you know mistakes
but I I can't take responsibility for
that it's the world I've I grew up in
that conditioned me to believe that if
you're in some sort of powerful position
you have to be a man yes that's not your
fault it's not my fault okay fifth and
final story a little old but you see
nonetheless um Megan Marco through a
quote sayonara Zara party after she got
rich and it should have been called
sighisoara the taxpayers are gonna love
this is that what they were owed her you
some no me okay once upon a time there
lived a beautiful woman named this is
Venus of course they would trash Meghan
Marco who was not yet a higher earning
TV star not yet the wife of Prince Harry
and not yet a duchess who lived in a
palace that woman was more like the rest
of us meaning she's shocked at Zara now
that there's anything wrong with Sarah
on the contrary the popular Spanish
retailer is considered among the higher
end of the affordable clothing stores
and both scourges styles yes and their
prices are going up and you know that's
just not what that's not what we agreed
to
no their prices are going up and their
style is going down it's turning into
theory where it's like if you need
outfits for a business conference hedges
are but it used to be if you wanted like
a cool jumpsuit that like not everyone
had Zara was the place and it wouldn't
be more than 49.99 yes one yes maybe
that squirt that they made that
literally took New York by storm yes and
one summer they made a skort that was X
Kurt and shorts it had like a little
thing
everyone wore it everywhere I had to
yeah I can't remember glass I'm I went
to Zara me neither and I literally live
right by one that's so we used to like
go like twice a year like for the
seasons change even though after school
yeah but they really have gone downhill
and their prices have gone up hill and
shopping right it's expiry and shopping
online there is virtually impossible
they're so androgynous you never know if
the shirt was made for a man or a woman
which I know we don't see gender but
sometimes I need to know how to order a
size I know we don't see gender but some
people have large breasts you know it
was just so stupid and it's like there's
no men's section and you can't tell it
the models it's just it's the worst
online shopping experience the pictures
are so big you can't find the Add to
Cart button yeah and it's not made for
mobile it's not a friendly anyways but
you won't find prices anywhere close to
four figures sorry and they had one too
many of those like Holocaust faux pas
you know accidentally selling shirt with
like the yellow star I mean look that's
not an accident that can't happen more
than once
first time I was forgiving second time I
was like what right
like third time I give me to hire like a
Jew who's like I'm offended - yeah we're
and just everyone and I do believe
sometimes things like that happened and
it's like it's just like it fell through
the cracks and I don't believe that was
any bad intention and just nobody
realized this was like oddly
anti-semitic right like kind of
associate there's like a Nazi designer
sleeping it in but well you haven't one
too many times now Mike okay where's up
Heinrich Himmler hiding in the Zara HQ
and the other like one too many rats and
dress stories oh oh my god and I do
enough people know that story I don't
know but what's so crazy about that
story is that I take the world by storm
and Jackie knows the girl she's my very
good friend from college tell the story
jack um so I think she's trying to move
past it in her life don't say names but
a girl who whether I would literally
never move past it I would like go on
the Today Show and like a literally milk
it for all that it's worth for sure
except I don't make my Instagram exam
rat girl except I don't think that she
could because it would have limited the
amount of money that she got from Zara
because the more she talked about it the
less they had to keep her quiet totally
I'm gonna shut your mouth right so um
but it's all settled now and I think she
did okay uh she was at work one day
wearing
freshly showered she had noted because I
think s that was like she's one of those
people you know it could go either right
I know and they wanted to make it seem
like maybe it was no but I think she was
no she was just sitting at work and she
knew that she had washed your hair and
done it fresh that morning wearing
dress from Zara and it's like maybe like
around three o'clock in the afternoon
like she starts to smell something like
so foul and she was like I know it's not
me because I really did try where she's
like smelling herself everywhere and she
like can't figure out the source oh my
god I actually really wish i dint o to
tell the story I'm not getting so
nauseous and then she laid her fat like
it there's like a scratch on her leg and
she like goes to like Poland she thinks
it's a thread long story short it's a
tale there was a dead rat sewn into her
dress and that's what she was smelling
image she thought it was a little tag
she pulled it and it was the bats
[ __ ] tail yeah and she got a rat
borne bruise - I wrote in porn rash okay
so and just she got a settlement for
Zara and this one you think you think
put in savings but I think she did I
think she went in savings she seems
worse fiscally actually I'm kidding I
think she did okay that is the craziest
story like and it was on the cover of
the New York Post was my Mirren highest
one it was at the height of Zara like it
was the craziest thing uh-huh
and so now I just present like only it
that would only happen to her why cuz
she's so prim and proper no she just has
like all these crazy like so just like
like so you know like how we say about
Bethenny you know yeah like it's like
Bethenny her life is more interesting
than Carol's right and you deserve to
talk more in the friendship right she's
a good storyteller too so it really
happened to the right person cuz she was
able to if you were to tell you the
story she told me the story over text
and I felt like I was I was on the edge
of my seat should she'll have the text
so just some curious oh not it wouldn't
be on this phone I'd have to go
searching a Hollywood source recently
told Vanity Fair that when Megan star
was rising she threw herself she threw
herself really long right she threw
herself a party at her home unofficially
billed as a sayonara Zara party and gave
away the lower price clothes in her
closet to her guests of course nowadays
as duchess of sussex you'll find Meghan
wearing top styles by the likes of
grappler end Stella McCartney Burberry
and Siobhan Shay the designer of her
wedding dress her sister-in-law Kate
Middleton also sports designer looks bet
has occasionally warns are closing
jewelry as a royal as well prompting
items to sell out well here's the thing
maybe she had a sayonara Zara party
because um she was on the up and up but
maybe she had it because Zara is over
right it's like a little obnoxious out
to invite like your peasant friends over
and give them like your dirty t-shirts
like rude like
Zarah is great for a lot of things was
great for a lot of things but like
they're not necessarily things that you
need to like pass down we're very much
like disposable clothing yeah well not
anymore she worn it right not it but at
at this time that just seems like it I'm
not just thing to do like it's throwing
a party to tell them I'm like hey I'm
successful I'm rich and you're not you
want my dirty underwear with the [ __ ]
stain on it
yes please but you can sell them now
they can sell it right so I just thought
that was like an interesting thing I
just like it's an interesting fact right
that's interesting and it also like I
just it's it helps to build this profile
of Megan in my brain like we get very
little real information about her I do
believe that this happened so when I'm
trying to think I'm is I'm like is my
goodness diva extraordinaire that the
public is making her out to see me or is
she really just like a nice girl and
this is helping build my internal
profile of Megan Marvel which will in
turn help me decide what type of person
she is
right this is very diva ask for sure and
for me I'm just gonna sit on my hands
and wait probably around six years until
it's explained in the crown but you know
I'm very patient yeah so I can do that
you're nothing if not patient no I
really I am and we'll come back six
years or man I'll say right I just I
just waited yeah anyways are you ready
to recap The Bachelor the world's long
as the most boring show no but we I
asked everyone I said if you want me to
recap the bachelor come only doing it
for you and I did get people who wanted
us to do it so I'm a woman of the people
and I'm gonna do what they want and I
did I watch I watched very half-assed
Lee I was blowing out my hair and doing
other such things but I do love Colton
and like that's just that makes it a
little easier to withstand because like
when you can't stand the bachelor or the
Bachelorette it's like why am I even
watching this you know right I really do
like him I watched half hazard Lee as
well because I didn't I I guess I missed
the first impression Rose like I must
have fast forwarded over at my Tivo was
being like oh he was actually really
cute um and I knew who's gonna be here
like I could tell because like she's
gorgeous and so cute and I had one very
not memorable interaction it was just
really sweet they made a lot of eye
contact they were both really nervous
and they were like talking about her
nervous and it was obviously she had
like a prepared question just to like
start the conversation she was like so
when you play football is that scarier
than like when you're on the back there
like a very normal average question
she's just like a so sweet and they're
perfect for each other and I think she
wasn't really yeah
but she has to here's the
first I'm the girl on the batch lor the
first impression rose winner never wins
but but on the Bachelorette the first
impression rose winner usually wins and
I think it's because women have more an
intuition of an intuition and a better
sense of like judgment where's kind of I
think guys get distracted by look look
Colton is like so different than every
bachelor we've ever had like he's a
little feminine yeah did you see his
dancing elf video yeah he's a little bit
yes I also her Instagram is premium I
know I followed her last night she's so
pretty and remember when we went to
lunch and The Bachelor promo pictures
came out and we were like a content
creator no we were like oh my god this
is like the worst looking group of women
I've ever seen
they make them all terrible looking oh
my god those pictures are so false
advertising this is the prettiest group
like everyone is beautiful there are so
many beautiful girls
no totally but they really all look the
same because when I first saw that thing
I was like oh my god calls not screwed
like there's really not anyone here but
he has his pick of Olympia he sent home
girls last night who were a plus
drop-dead gorgeous
yeah when that girl was crying like it
was really sad and all the girls were
like laughing behind her like yeah we're
going it was so sad but you know what
like she was a broadcast journalist and
like now him and Ari both sent home like
the people who work in TV night one
what's so funny like a good thing yes
but it's like those people like never
really even turn out to be the
thirstiest it's like just the girls who
don't work like who just want to have
Instagram followers like who are the
thirstiest right but it's a good
indicator yes I great I want to talk
about the Katherine of it so I guess we
can never go on yeah because we work in
a network show right working media it's
11:00 12:00 we missed it Chet will you
still do it Network show Network show
Network show Network show Network show
network network show
I'm sure someone has a slow clock and
it's still 11:11 I really want to talk
about the Katherine of it all because
like it's it's the first episode formula
like there's a girl who's taking too
much of the time and they sent her down
and she has understand and she's other
and I'm very much of the mindset now
it's like well whoever the bachelor
producers decide this person is gonna be
the villain and we're gonna make
everyone not like them they did it with
Jordan
they did it with Corinne and AJ but
it'll be accreting and I'm no longer
subscribing to that narrative so I'm
looking at it from the angle it's like
you know they're telling her to go up go
up they say okay Katherine it's your
chair and go interrupt okay Katherine in
church and go interrupt sudden they chop
it all together of the girls complaining
about her interrupt
her interrupting because I told her to
and then them having the conversation
being like we may lunge anything it's
annoying that girl was really [ __ ]
annoying she was giving me Taylor Nolan
vibes for sure and it's like you never
want to be that person like if you're
cool like just and if she really is a
villain and like being annoying and rude
like her true colors will show like you
don't need to be the person to call her
out like but she's not ability like she
was just doing she was told you know
that right but even if they didn't tell
her like those conversations really are
30 seconds to a minute every time we saw
someone interrupt her she had just
started speaking so like when she said
it was 30 seconds to a minute she was
like no it was longer than that it was
not longer than that mind you they
wrapped filming what looks like to be 8
a.m. you know honestly no the Sun was at
like peak strength it was noon okay so
these girls have had all night to talk
to him and a great oh my god that's so
we know you didn't get up and talk to
him and insert yourself in there I'm
sorry but that's on you I couldn't even
wait around like you sit on your looks
because like you're so pretty and like
you don't think you need to work hard
but not anymore it's a girl who like
really wants to talk to you that's gonna
make an effort it's grace to the
narrative it's like it's one night it's
a cocktail party but it's a full 12
hours and if you can't find time for a
one-minute conversation there's 30 girls
there they all get a minute that's a
half hour you have 12 hours and people
who blame the fact that they haven't had
time on the girl who has had multiple
times know you're insecure and you're
not confident in yourself don't [ __ ]
talk to him it's not her fault she
probably came in late and this is
generous probably took up eight to ten
minutes of those maybe say 10 minutes
yeah in a 12 hour evening I just hate
that formula where it's like oh well
we've had success where there's a person
in the first episode who's taking up a
lot of time and then there's a villain
it's if they decided the second she
walked out we're gonna make her the
villain like they just chose her I like
her vibe though me too I enjoyed her a
lot she's very Corinne she's very Korean
like she was wearing a mini dress which
just shows like I'm not gonna take this
like way too seriously this isn't a
patch I'm not putting on my Cinderella
ball gown right I got like stupid she
got sent home
right Cinderella she was really cute
yeah I know I was actually surprised
that she got sent home maybe she just
didn't talk to she didn't know she was
one of those people just like stop
acting like because she's pretty raw I
didn't carriage like she thought that
what was enough and then they zoomed to
the pumpkin that was kind of funny yeah
very funny they're like that editorial
spin um
and Catherine I hope she like kind of
makes it far one because she's keeping
it a little interesting and two because
like I think she would make a really
great revolve influencer because she was
wearing a revolve Michael Costello dress
and she looked incredible and I would
make a good bachelor in paradise girl
too oh for sure
and she's a rock
check out her in CV a bachelor in
paradise and rockin bod there were so
many parts of this show like the live
show that was so cringy but probably the
worst part was the goose in Crystal a
hot tub missed it
Jackie they literally just kept opening
every commercial break with her dancing
in the hot tub
Krystal it was so weird stop oh and they
were are you pregnant cuz he looks set
on their Instagram like will you go that
like she like was and then they never
spoke about it and they're like are you
extending your family and they're like
being so weird and ominous and they're
like yeah we're getting a dog
it was so stupid like I didn't
understand the whole thing yeah and then
he also posted last night one of the
toasters put in the group like they're
making their own reality they said that
we got a reality TV show and then they
said to watch it go to YouTube and like
our YouTube right when we get to 10,000
subscribers we'll do some [ __ ] that's
like us saying we got a network show go
to the youtube.com session morning toast
yeah that's your network and it's called
glitter and the goose and I just want to
say no one ever called him the goose
like he's gonna say when they showed up
to paradise calling himself goose okay I
missed that because when they were
saying Gustavson I thought it was
sponsored by Grey Goose no he like was a
weirdo on who season was he on Beca
that's right he was weird or on back of
season like wrote a song and was weird
and then went home then came from Howard
I thinking he was like HBIC I was so
confused and calls himself the goose and
then like she once said something about
sparkles and now their show like now
she's throwing my glitter like that's
not the same thing you know that's like
me and Ben going by like no I don't even
know cuz I get so far-fetched and also
like what's wrong with Chris and Krystal
like that's yeah I know your names are
literally the same right weird
weirdness ever scenes let's talk about
the other hosts because I'm I didn't see
the mom the only one that I liked liked
in would have wanted to be at was the
Jojo and Kaitlyn won cuz it was a great
were definitely drinking and like they
were having a good time the Ashley I and
Jared like I can't and in the proposal
shent
of the proposed and blinkin and the
vampire and Ben Higgins
who's the chasing yeah they were like in
someone's apartment like they got
shafted oh I didn't see they didn't get
like the good lighting I'm there to
people who like wanted to be the
bachelor and it's like wow how the
mighty have fallen
it's actually Blake
because like he left on the best
possible note like everyone loves him
fortunately I haven't even seen him a
lot and like that's how you're gonna
come back cause they been the cocktail
party started and he made that little
speech being like you know I know how
scary it is like I fell in love with
that guy like you tell me he was gonna
cry like he had like you need to get the
lump in your throat yes I think you had
that also a lot of the girls I don't
know if it was the light reflecting off
their eyeballs but it looks like they
Ward they're drunk that their eyes were
so glassy and when they put that salmon
in the pool and you really think next
day they're all gonna like just they lay
around and and tan and swim the whole
day that was disgusting there was salmon
in the pool this girl like as a Fisher
or some [ __ ] and then she put a full
salmon in the pool like a swimming
salmon and she caught it oh my god yeah
but the little kitschy like stick is
getting old like that groped the girl
who was a dancer who like brought a full
symphony so stupid their address was
horrible and we need to talk about the
wardrobe stylist with Jackie you had the
funniest Instagram what did you say I
said not trying to be mean because I
really was trying to keep it positive
and light and you know what some of
those girls are either toasters or going
to be toasters are gonna come on this
show and I'm really not trying to be
unnecessarily mean but the girl who's a
wardrobe stylist who showed up at the
fete as the fashion police needs to
arrest or sell
she was the worst dress and she made her
whole stick of outside she was wearing
Sheena's wedding dress like crop top she
was wearing a cut wife beater unclear on
the bra with the mermaid skirt sequin
skirt and it was just god-awful yeah
those pieces separately were awful and
then together even worse a symphony of
awfulness right it was like that work is
sure that we brought in but when they
were dancing Colton is like he's like
shy but he there's personality there I
think he's actually gonna take a while
to like blossom like a flower like he's
not used to all this attention because
he got like 10 minutes on Beca season
but I'm just so looking forward to
getting to know my one true love and the
Virgin thing is getting so high any sofa
anyone who came in saying virgin God
meet you and I don't know what this girl
left but one girl who they showed like a
one-on-one she had like five minutes she
was like so you're a virgin
why right it was like so rude I can't
accept his answer was was perfectly if
he was like I just like I never got to
it and now now it's a thing right I
really him he for whatever reason he
there's there is some reason he's a
virgin whether it's religious or
whatever I don't care the fact that
everyone's making it seem like this is
the weirdest thing it's just it like
proof of how disgusting our generation
is like no everyone should have sex when
they're 14 you know also like relatively
young it's not like he's nick Vile's age
he's forty five seven four he's he's
either he's 24 to 26 and that's when him
and Hannah gee I think it was her that
had the conversation or maybe it was
someone else he that's just like like
that she said she's young and he was
like I just feel older I'm like I wanna
I want to get married and have kids like
things that people do when they're 30 I
want to do now and he was like I got a
lot of [ __ ] last season cuz I was so
young but like I still have want the
same things as a 30 year old right I
don't think it's weird I've like Colton
and I'm still not here for like the
hating of him no I really like him the
rest of the season looks so crazy I know
they always make it look crazy yeah then
they lose him you probably didn't see it
but they did like a mash up of all the
people who are either married or have
had babies from the bath Sharon it was
like a really cute that like went to
their houses and Jane and Tanner were on
there and they asked her something about
like becoming a mom and like she was
crying and it was so cute and they had
like JP and Ashley and Trisha Trista and
Ryan and it was a really cute little
bathroom no they weren't on there that's
but they had um Evan and Carly Jade and
Tanner and Evan and Carly were like
we're just really happy to be a part of
like the babies club like the cool
that's like the cool Club that's like
that actual Hall of Fame like you'll
always get a paycheck in some way from
them yeah they'll always reach out to
you
we're rachel and brian on the know but
like she's really one of the only one of
the few with actual hosting experience
and she lives in Dallas that's weird I
know that's weird I always wonder what
like the back like logistics are like
who gets what
right and who know Ashlee I get every
opportunity in the book could then die
for a while like Caitlin didn't he's
there - did they address the Shawn thing
not another part that I had my head up
for you know yeah maybe when I was
blow-drying my hair they addressed it
but I feel like I would have seen it no
and it also was all very light-hearted
and yeah that has to be like a
one-on-one with Chris Harrison yeah not
like in a bar no but Nick Viall did do a
whole podcast on his relationship with
Kaitlyn and he said that he didn't say a
lot of this for a while out of respect
for Kaitlyn and Shawn's relationship
because it was too serious but not that
they're not together he thinks he could
say whatever he wants and someone
obviously didn't listen too excited
never give him that so I was
action but a toaster did a recap in the
toaster scrub and was actually quite
humble also like it pains me to say a
nice thing but the name of his podcast
is actually cute what is it
the Nick vile files okay it should have
been called the vile files but it's fine
but he needs he's thirsty household name
in there funny someone sent you
Catherine and Sean just left for
vacation do it Oh cute good for them
like putting their own happiness over
like this happiness of Chris Harrison
Chris Harrison's mom and his Bar Mitzvah
montage it kind of gave me vibes that
like this was the last season really I
mean I was really hoping but no it
didn't you guys have anything other than
it's like now that he's single it's very
much like why don't you become the
bachelor yeah you know why why why why
well cuz they'd have to get older but
like a like a crop god forbid ya know
and they won't do that they get some
eligible women who like talk a bit who
don't use anything wins by the way oh I
don't know why any of them too well but
I think Hanna definitely like goes far
always first impression rose like you
know even if even if he doesn't like her
like her looks will get hurt too maybe
right before hometowns depending on if
she's crazy which she was amazing
and she didn't seem crazy in the
previews I think the girl who um who was
Miss who the water line of two pageant
girls not the one with the sash well she
definitely goes far but not like top 14
you know the sash was really stupid but
also Hanna was missing Alabama something
I went on her website last night really
she didn't talk about it but she must've
been in a different year like they
compete against each other but I think
the other girl mm-hmm the other PI think
I think she goes far she's got a good
intuition for that like I literally will
be like I don't see a connection with
anyone like you saw you saw Lauren B and
Ben and I was like you and you said her
name I was like who's Lauren B I didn't
know her yet like that's how
non-intuitive I am whereas like you pick
up on very subtle rillette connections
and you are always right it's settled
connections like cuz I literally
remember when they had it like when it's
hard to find things to talk about and
even that night one conversation
wouldn't like everyone's talking about
themselves
it's unless you're like really pretty
it's really hard to stand out you know
or really weird in which case like
you're probably going in a negative way
right so when and even on like the
one-on-one dates down the line like
everyone says the same things and like
she you said something like so cute
about her dad and his yard and how he
just loves
yard and she just wants like a life like
that no and she also when when there was
a lot going on and she wasn't really
like involved in the drama he pulled her
aside and and gave her a picture of them
he was like I know I'd like haven't
really been talking to you at all you
know I'm thinking of you and it was
really sweet it's a sweet and she was
the only when he told that his dad like
was sick a little bit so that's when I
really felt strongly um but then also
telltale signs if you're doing your
bracket and you don't want to spoilers
based on the music that this show is in
no spoiler zone for the batch are right
if you spoil in the comments like you of
shine Idol too many states out of every
group yes but um the music that plays
when they walk out of the limo will
determine like if their import like not
everyone has an interesting limb on exit
because they don't know at that point
who's gonna win but usually the first
person out of the limo is going far
because that's who the bachelor
producers think is like wife material
always like the firt limo number one um
is like the best girls is what they say
but I didn't see that last night I think
they switched up the orders so music
that plays at during your introduction
and what I've also goes if you have a
package in the beginning where you oh we
got to I didn't I missed all that mhm
it doesn't necessarily mean anything no
that chicken enthusiast girl had like
the longest package and she literally
went so not far right like I don't think
like Brian had a package yeah oh he did
um anyways I'm not gonna haul it for as
bad as it could have been it wasn't
terrible but the the hot spa the nerve
of a three hour episode like two hours
is already like my absolute limit three
hours I really hope they don't make this
a habit and just to have all that like
fluff is garbage I couldn't agree more
trash and then I wonder who the next
pack chart will be they'll be like so
many good options yes so then there was
like that little girl who looks to be
like to be like the villain later on
she'd like really long hair I think that
he was like D or something I don't
remember anyone's name Oh I mean
honestly there but I because I really
wasn't paying attention this time oh
here's a girl who's never been kissed oh
that was weird I saw that that was
perfect for you but she was really cute
yeah
that made me so late for Vanderpump
rules and I really like to live tweet
because the cows they they live tweet it
and like they're still fighting in real
life so I hate not watching it live
except that like
lalla Brittany and Jax are on the
vacation of a lifetime have you been
watching of course I've never grown a
yacht what I like search them every day
they seem like they're having the best
time
well apparently Jax and Randall are in
love and I'm in love with Jackson ran me
to last night's episode was good it was
a little anticlimactic because like they
made it seem like Rambo had this big
fight like he was literally upstairs and
she was just like drunk and being
annoying whatever right but it's gonna
have like consequences you know I was
thinking about the whole time when
Taylor Stryker co-hosted with you
she said that those parties that she
goes to when they film are fun but they
can't play music so it's like not that
fun oh my goodness she's statement to
you though because I've never heard that
she probably knew I was actually
thinking like that party looked fun
because like everyone there is having
fun and drinking but like the where's
the music where's the dancing so they're
not allowed to play music because it'll
interrupt with the audio so she's like
it's I mean it's not quiet because
everyone's there like drinking screaming
laughing but like it's missing something
that is so I literally was thinking that
yeah I was looking for Taylor Stryker I
couldn't find her in Episode I really
was thinking what makes a party so great
and fun I was it gets the music so like
maybe a pool party would have been more
fun but no they just need the music at
that party everyone came in themed like
Vanderpump rules like respects the theme
for sure
except for la la what what the hell was
she wearing she I well first of all they
haven't addressed yet but she's not
drinking like I don't think she drank
that night and she's been sober for a
while yeah and she like had like I think
right now she's consistently sober but
like she was like doing like dry spells
for a while she definitely wasn't
drinking that night and like barely
showed up and maybe it's just cause like
off the death of her dad but she was
just taking a break right but she yeah I
feel like she's someone who would never
like miss an opportunity to dress up so
that was weird yeah oh my god her ass is
amazing so was Brittany but Brittany
looked so good when she was like that's
like the worst position to laying naked
yes except like I'm not here for like
the white eyelashes of everyone it needs
a costume no but it made everyone like
look weird it's like I have white
eyelashes and like I would kill to not
Katie looks really good like scared
everyone looks scary yeah like not in a
good way
and I do want to say except Ariana's has
he looks great and they looked so happy
and like scheana was right when she know
when she was in the corner and she was
like it's so weird to see Ariana like be
so obsessed with Stassi when Ariana used
to give scheana the most [ __ ] for trying
to be friends with those girls and like
now that's all
but like they treat Ariana like an equal
they used to treat Sheena like lesser
and that's why Ariana because it's like
scheana was trying so I'm gonna give no
but you imagine for Sheena who was stuck
in the middle for so long Ariana was
like don't be friends with those girls
but really what she really wanted was
like to be with the cool girls now to
see that girl be like best friends
twins wearing the same hair like it's
weird and I'm never one to like defend
Sheena but like I would be pissed yeah
that whole atom thing is so weird and
she is literally not on the show no and
she's like doing these things to be on
the show if she didn't pay less she has
to be I don't think so I don't think so
either because I think she gets paid
what she's gonna get paid regardless of
it she's interesting and she's older she
filmed just she still works up sir she
goes to all the parties but it's just
like she doesn't have a lot going on
because she does and they really aren't
friendly with her in the Vanderpump
world
sassy said a couple of things last night
that were literally the funniest things
I've ever heard
first of all when she said um when she
was talking that how much she loved Bo
and then she's like oh my god do I sound
like Sheena talking he that Rob that was
so funny and then she said one other
thing and I sat on my couch laughing for
a minute straight and now obviously I
can't remember it but she was she was in
rare form
on her side commentary yeah yes I agree
um there was like not that many people
at the party know Raquel came so stupid
I want to talk about Brittney and Jax
and Tom and Ariana
I love how Lala firmly took a side of
Britney and Jackson like ran like a like
a little rat and rat it out to I like
that
and I I'm filling an agreement I really
don't like how much Tom Sandoval and
Ariana like talk about Jackson Britney
like they're you know I can't speak
English like in a negative way and
talking about the death of Jax's dad
like you can't talk about someone the
death like however he's choosing to to
internalize it like that's not your
[ __ ] business and definitely is
jealous cuz Ariana does want to get
married yeah and at one point like Tom
and Ariana we're like the coolest couple
like relationship gold like and now not
so much no not so much anything dropping
a hard time with that yeah Tom looks
just so scary everyone like looked scary
did you watch watch happens live with
Lisa no they made such a good call and I
was thinking and also Therese had peace
was to reach here I thought it
immediately um but they did an
interesting game I watched up inside and
they put up all the girls and they also
included a Bailey which was beard it was
like she's not a cast member and they
would make the best whatever
they said who would make the best real
housewife obviously Lala what did Katie
Maloney like it was just yeah it was
like she went out of her way not to say
la la because it was the truest answer
they also had some other oh she said
who's the number-one girl on this group
and inaho Lisa said saucy yes she said
thank God she said it she has to like
everyone's are interesting gamers I came
to pretend like sassy like is it there
on the scoop in that like and then she's
like she's done eating [ __ ] like [ __ ]
eating season is over like let her ask
her I know what it was that you thought
like that Stassi said she used all the
words that Patrick that Patrick like
condescending towards her in a sentence
she's like I don't want to use this
relationship look at this relationship
myopically
yeah but I am ready to galvanize that
was really that was so funny ya know
he's really good cheese yeah right she
was really in rare form what else have
you like and then she laughed at her own
joke she was so pleased right there's
James's mom that was James's family
involvement is like really weird and
really sad and I'm watching upins live
and he said like you had the greatest
one-liner of all time she goes to Lisa
he really looks up to you as a mother
figure Lisa goes you're his mom that's
what's up my job it's yours I don't know
about the greatest one line of all time
no no like and that is weird to like go
to like admit that you're a bad mom even
though you're very much in like his life
it's not like you know dawn Atwood going
to Kirsten Cohen and being like you're
more of a mom to Ryan he's like saying
it so she can get James his job back
like it's like his whole family is like
really riding his coattails but like no
totally like it's really a responsible
of the parents like okay if his younger
brother is one like be fake DJ's for a
couple years like that's not their son
Colin it's harmless but its parent like
his dad lives with Paul and Paul is um
was that like pk no no no Paul is a
brother no Paul is like either from the
beginning of this season or last season
he was like James was like living with
him he was like this older man it's a
class season things I couldn't get you
dinner it was all very weird and he was
like living and like in a bedroom made
out of a futon like a one of those
dressing curtains
so now his dad's living with that guy
what yeah when I heard it I mentally go
back to pay tons because I thought maybe
it was pique because they're all like
faring yeah but it's all weird because
like James came in and he was like this
like rich British kid whose dad was
friends with George Michael and his
friends with Lisa family friends of Lisa
so it doesn't make any sense it's
confusing wow I'm really over like the
Raquel storyline I so don't care no
semen it's like okay if she agrees with
all you guys and breaks up with James
then like that's it goodbye to reality
TV right she's like there that's the one
thing they're not saying we know you
want to be if they said to her break up
a James so we can get him off of our
show will be will be your friend and
will let you on the show of course she
would look at you and job it sir this
isn't the great love of 2019 you know
yeah I agree it was a good episode
though it was I just they keep leaving
it on cliffhangers like this where it's
like the thing that they chew up in the
preview is like the last minute of the
show yeah and that's kind of like a
thirsty bachelor movemove and i don't
think that they need it like that i
completely like i'm gonna watch next
week regardless as long as everyone's
gonna show up and we'll get a little
more Lala I'll watch I could use a
little bit more there's just so many
cast mates now that like it's literally
impossible to put them all in one
episode so someone has to be the focal
point in this time too so seeing Ariana
and maybe a lot like he's got like was
filming last because like she was I
guess she's not engaged yet yeah there's
like when she was sitting with Brittany
talking about the engage in the ring
like it was so cute does she get engaged
on camera no I don't think so
like right afterwards
yeah I think they probably did it
intentionally otherwise like Randa would
have to be on the show right and he's
not down for that maybe next like once
they're married like he should be and he
really he says he wants Instagram
followers like he got Kendall Chloe
Khloe and Scott to post about him yeah I
followed him um I really love them me
too
so much I just love la la she looked
like I love her dark hair and I love the
red lips she looked so good she looks so
good in their trip look so if I'm like I
was everyone is gonna Bimini they were
yeah they wearing that Lantis know they
were at Atlantis then they took a boat
too though they're on the plane they
were filming while they were landing in
Bimini he was like that's Bimini it was
passing it I think they might have been
passing because they went to Atlanta
they docked they started and ended
in Atlantis ohdid then yes okay the
Bahamas just like so pop it now like
when we were like kids in Atlantis first
came like it was a hottest spot like we
went once a year like it was the local
holiday in the Sun like it was the
coolest spot then like I took a couple
years off and now like it's poppin it's
pop in there like many hotels many
islands I think it's that's actually
like might go to vacation meet you
because you get to leave the country for
that exotic feel but it's like very good
American Bahaman relations like you get
to do customs there not when you land
it's all good and there's a lot of
direct flights and it's maybe like 20
minutes longer than Florida everyone
speaks English like it's great yeah and
there's just so much fun in the Sun and
casino gambling for a holiday in the Sun
okay what else I feel like that's it for
today um I'm back tomorrow you're back
tomorrow have a very busy day today
preparing the house to do proofing the
house then we have thursday joey camasta
yes he's so funny and let's make sure to
hound him about like Jenni Roger I will
I feel like he knows a lot of stuff I
will and I still have that wig for him
what wig like he wanted my um Halloween
wig oh is that he wanted the Christian
already and I literally have I've been
keeping it for him and I was about to
throw it away then I was like oh you
know what maybe I'll he'll co-host soon
and now I'll give him well I should have
him do the whole show in a wagon I was
gonna say yeah I literally throw
everything away have him do the whole
show in a wig that would be so funny and
then Friday we have Olivia obviously
doing a full recap of her wedding and we
also have my wedding your wedding and
Olivia's wedding designer Josh truly the
mastermind behind the Australians season
so that'll be great so make sure you're
tuned in both days but we're back
tomorrow I'll be here tomorrow and then
I'm heading to Columbus and Cincinnati
where my shows are sold out so I
apologize deeply then I'm doing a big
show Saturday night in Detroit City go
to University of Michigan or anywhere
the surrounding universities feel free
to come by it's almost sold out I'm not
gonna lie the only seats left are in the
background but it's $35 like what else
did you expect so it's gonna be a good
time and then I have a bunch of shows
coming up we got Foxwoods we got
really haven't announced that yet but
very soon Dallas Houston and other shows
being added tampa orlando baltimore
Silver Spring just head to girl with
road job home for tickets and
availabilities show times coming soon to
a theater near you
hey anything you are plug well always
act Accio problems posting premium
content a lot of wedding content now
people who really enjoy that but really
enhances the feed yes and I'm glad that
like people other people enjoying it
like makes it a little bit more fun for
me because otherwise it's just
completely treacherous yep
so I've talked your problems premium as
hell app hop with no job you'll be able
to keep up on nephews weekend out oh you
look the NHS and that's all she wrote
have an amazing day stay in school
sayonara Zara sighs ara
you